[Music]
katie thurston's season of the
bachelorette kicked off with
make-out sessions and plenty of husband
potential to go around
the guys are so great this season during
monday's premiere
episode the 30 year old bank marketing
manager met
and charmed 30 men vying for her heart
you look amazing nice to meet you nice
to meet you but before the infamous
limo intros katie revealed that she's
never been in a relationship with
someone who's felt like her partner
something she said she hopes to remedy
as she searches for her soulmate
and looks ahead to an engagement i never
felt like i could be myself completely
but i'm happy where i'm at now i've
learned a lot about myself
and i am not going to settle i'm ready
for that love that i deserve
ahead of the premiere katie told et what
she's looking for in a man
the biggest thing is he has to be
passionate about life or what he's doing
in life definitely a good sense of humor
and then kindness i think that's a
really big thing that people kind of
overlook
it's a journey katie thought she'd go
through alone amid chris harrison's
decision to step
away from the franchise but the newest
franchise lead
was happy to find out that caitlyn
bristow and tasha adams were there to
help her out
i was just very blessed to have tasha
and caitlyn kind of help me through
that journey and it's something that i
will forever be thankful for
they help me from start to finish
they've gone through it it really means
something to me that girl power and that
bond but back to those limo intros
i'm really excited for everyone to get
to know these guys know their stories
because they have something great to
share
first up thomas who was pretty sweet
have just a deep admiration for you
stepping into this string and having the
hope to live in such a vulnerable way
then trey showed up in a ball pit in the
back of a pickup truck
i'm here to have a ball with you as you
can see because not only are you drop
dead gorgeous but uh
you're a pretty baller bash toy and
katie
she liked it check out what she told et
about trey
you can't deny the chemistry and the
energy that he offers like he just
lights up a room but trey wasn't the
only guy to think outside of the box
andrew s pulled up in a british car and
rocked a
fake british accent i'm traveling all
the way across the pond to be here with
you tonight
while jeff opted to roll up in an rv
they say homes where the heart is i
drove my home here from jersey
hoping you'd be my heart and there was a
whole lot of sexual innuendos
like this i don't know if there's a
genie in here
but i'm hoping we can rub one out
together the guy can't accept you know
me being sex positive or talking about
sex it's just not gonna work out
there are some people who are a little
traditional in old school but you know
but people around my age and younger
like we're here for is 2021 embrace your
sexuality and
be empowered woman then there was conor
bee
who came dressed up as a cat and katie
she was into it i think i'm in love
like really into it so much so that
katie and the cat had a major makeout
session when things moved inside
but connor b wasn't the only guy to get
a kiss katie puckered up to justin the
painter too
and she told et he's just one of those
guys who surprises you
he's very talented as an artist but he's
very sexy and mysterious as well
katie also kissed greg when she gave him
the coveted first
impression rose after he gifted her with
a homemade necklace from his niece
i do feel that there's something there
and once we can get past those nerves
i think there's a great guy under there
so why did katie give greg that first
rose here's what she told e.t
greg was just so authentically himself
like he was like i'm nervous i'm scared
of what i'm doing and that's what i
loved about him he wasn't trying to be
too cool
and after katie sent a few of the men
packing she dished on seeing some real
long-term potential with the remaining
guys
there's so many good guys in that room
the kind of guys who have that long-term
potential i'm just really excited i'm
excited for
what's to come katie wouldn't spill on
her current relationship status but she
did tell et
that she falls in love more than once
during her time on the show
i'm engaged to myself that's what i've
been saying for now i'm very happy